jaco derisi is a true professional a
veteran goes out there with several
pitches to try and compete for starts of
the season
swing and a miss odor rizzy gets jd
martinez on three pitches picking up his
first strikeout of the day
ground ball right side julie guriel
stays with it flips to odorizzi covering
and that'll do it for the boston red sox
at the top of the first inning what hit
one man left on base martin perez three
and two with a 355. yeah that 355 leads
all boston starters he's really been on
a roll the last six starts three for six
overall two home runs in the series he's
going to lift this one into left center
and moving on over oh santana made the
catch bradugo came right in front of him
and danny made the adjustment went down
to get it whoa that was a fake pump of
the century right there diaz now takes
off for third and he's thrown out and
the inning is over
so diaz took off perez hadn't lifted his
leg and oledmi's diaz is thrown out at
third so raphael will lead things off
here in the second inning fly ball
center field straw back turning around
that's off the wall now he has to
scamper after it raphael into second
base he'll stop there
didn't miss a home run by that much
finally he crushed that ball i can't
believe this ball didn't go out it takes
a jolt to hit it out there 3-2 that's
high
for ball four
renfro works out a walk and the red sox
have two on with nobody out now it's
christian arroyo looking for a big hit
he'll swing high fly ball into left
field that ball is deep back goes jones
turning around and it's into the
crawford boxes that is a three-run homer
for christian arroyo
his first of the season red sox lead it
3-0 here in the second boy that'll get
him going boy he needed that big time
and good for him man he's been through a
lot with that hand injury he gets
himself his first home run a three-run
johnson in the crawford boxes
boston leads three to nothing top of the
third two outs runners on the corners
there goes the runner pitches up the
throw here comes the runner home
altuve's throw will be in time to get
devers trying to go in head first red
sox trying to steal a run there
and debra's thrown out at home plate on
a throw by jose altuve
and only paredes is coming out of the
bullpens that's a very short outing for
rotorusi went three
giving up three runs on four hits
inside corner at the knees perfect pitch
by enoli perei is picking up a strikeout
looking for out number two
as santana sends one to center field
straw on the move still going back at
the track puts it away on the warning
track santana gave it a pretty good ride
on the 2-0 pitch but he's out number
three only paradis will walk one man
left on base still three-nothing boston
2-2
popped up
into short right racing out arroyo to
make an adjustment down he goes
made a really nice play there and a
tough one to hang on and that's out
number two he almost overran that big
time
reached back and got it it's like no
man's land right there a little triangle
but he gets there enough time reaches
back little snow cone too
but here's christian javier taking over
for the astros in the fifth inning
getting another opportunity out of the
bullpen
and he takes a close one for ball four
good eye there and a good start to the
inning for the red sox and jd martinez
who struck out in flight out gonna crank
that one
that's headed for the wall
that slams into it picked up by jones
verdugo down to third into second with a
stand-up double it's jd martinez
red sox in business here in the fifth
called third strike outside corner
bogarts
who was frustrated last time with a line
drive to jose altuve gets called out on
a borderline pitch for out number one
they're gonna walk devers here with a
base open and that will load them up for
a hunter renfro
called third strike bottom of the zone
javier picks up back to back called
third strikes with the intention to walk
in between
and there's two away in the inning
runners staying at second and third at
first
swinging a miss he worked around a
second and third no out situation with
three strikeouts in the inning
javier
coming in out of the bullpen keeps the
game three nothing we're halfway home
and el tuve will lead it off against
martin perez who's been so effective
today he's allowed only four hits
and that's in there for strike three
and afterwards bending the knees of
altuve as he will take a seat that is
the second strikeout for martine
and a high fly ball but not deep enough
into left center santana again and
that's all martin perez gets the one two
three jd with a double last time up we
do go off the bag with nobody out not
running
and that one's going to be tagged that's
going to get down into left field to the
warning track scooped up by jones perdue
go around into third and sliding in with
another double jd martinez
his second double
in his many at bats that's an important
development as anything the fact that
he's starting to swing it again sox in
business again nobody out second and
third javier deals
there's a line shot that one's down into
the corner and a fair ball that'll skip
up against the wall that'll score two
for do go in martinez in wow it's gotta
feel good for bogey a two-run double to
make it five to nothing he breaks up an
old for 24. i think he was sitting on
breaking ball that whole bat with two
strikes that's why he fouled off that
fastball late got a decent breaking ball
he stayed on it lines it down the left
field like clearly a double two rbi on
this play and he needed this so bad
and martine will stay on to pitch
it's just been outstanding 57 pitches 42
strikes yeah the one it's 57 pitches
that's you know not unbelievable one two
there you go well there's another one on
the outside edge he throws him right
there
he punches out alvarez caught admiring
it
up the middle one hopper the flip on for
the force play bogart gets there and
that retires the side red sox with a
five-nothing lead over the astros bottom
of the eighth
oh yes
in there for strike three the coupler is
at work again that's his third pair of
shoes four on the day how about this
paintball he's throwing a couple
paintballs today beautiful thing to
straw to start off this eighth inning
little cutter cutter on the corner gotta
have it yes to a new pitcher someone we
haven't seen in a little while just
recently off the injured list blake
taylor
got him with the fastball up welcome
back blake taylor picking up his first
strikeout off the il two away in the
inning
three fastballs got him up top
good inning for blake taylor an infield
hit a couple of strikeouts brandon
workman as he returns to the red sox he
began the year with the cubs he put in
10 games before they dfade him on april
29th
right past him struck him out long day
for alvarez oh for four two punches
they'll face guriel
that ball's drilled deep to left field
shutout over
yuli guriel with la pina power for the
eighth time this year hitting a home run
it's now a five to one game
way to go julie that home run is a third
hit on the day for him
there it is swinging
the ball game red sox win it they had to
have that one
5-1
so they win the last game here in
houston texas